I've seen some people on the right track
if you're feeling a bit confused
at the moment that's okay this is just
that I just want to see some pictures
here and we're going to do a lot of
observation and talking through what's
going on I've actually got one two three
more we'll see how we go for space that
I want to talk about so did anyone think
of the other really simple one the other
one that you've been doing for like ten
years plus now simple operation that you
know it's inverse a pus apart from plus
and minus one of the other two
operations you learn about really
cooking you look really when you - plus
- look at your calculator your
operations their multiplication and
division right so for instance we had it
we talked about adding two and
subtracting two well if you multiply it
by two that that's a function I mean you
can multiply by any number you like then
it's inverse what would do what would go
in the reverse direction would be
division by two x on - okay again we can
draw a really simple graph of this
whoops wrong color one of these things
going to look like what X - X is is like
a Steve thing that goes through the
origin and Exxon - is a shallow thing
that goes through the origin yeah okay
and then that was this other one and
it's a bit tricky we talked about where
this topic is headed right which is
we're trying to learn how to
differentiate what kind of function
inverse trig functions right well we've
been working with the red streak
functions for a while so if for example
I think that's sine X and I think about
sine inverse of X something could be
interesting emerges okay now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna draw my sine X
here mm-hmm
maybe this guy as well when you start to
think about what does this guy look like
you run into some interesting problems
hmm let's pause for a minute before we
draw this guy I want to notice some
things about what we've got drawn here
before we move on any further okay
firstly when you have a look at the
three that I've drawn anyway I've got
the X plus two
X minus 2 I've got e to the X and log
base e to the X and then I've got 2x and
X on 2 we can think about these things
are in a few different ways firstly we
can think about them algebraically ok so
if we had for instance let's just do
this one over here okay if I said y
equals x plus 2 and y equals x minus 2
okay you can think about this remember I
said this is like reversing direction ok
you can think about this as reversing
variables ok it's really easy to find
out what the inverse is just by thinking
out the operation but I can also think
about it by switching X's and Y's and
we've talked about this before last year
if you remember if I take this guy and
reverse its variables here's the X and
the y I'm gonna swap their places x
equals y plus 2 yeah do you see how a
very simple manipulation if I make Y the
subject just turns it into that are you
ok with that
it's alright how about this y equals e
to the X what would happen when I switch
the variables well it'll be x equals e
to the Y which by definition is the way
that we would write this right you see
it's just the same equation I've just
rearranged it so that Y is the subject
same deal over here y equals 2x if I
switched variables and said x equals 2y
then all I have to do is divide both
sides by 2 and I get my function yeah so
here if I said y equals sine X it would
stand to reason that the way I would get
to this guy is by switching the
variables right so be something like
this ok now what you notice is the
direction of this thing is going to be
different just like the direction of
this and this and this is going to be
different but we still have more
problems to deal with which I want to
illustrate by saying not really
algebraically key think about this but
you can also think about it visually I
want you to take your page for me I
thought unfortunately can't use to the
whiteboard and I want you to turn your
page 45 degrees 45 degrees PI on 4 if
you prefer
80 clockwise can you do that for me
anti-clockwise you're spitting around
only 45 degrees okay now if you've draw
this accurately just you can tell you're
heavy you have to go the other way if
you turned your book in that direction
do you notice you should see symmetry in
what you've drawn can you see some
symmetry for example X minus 2 and X
plus 2 if you've turned them 45 degrees
they should look to you they should look
vertical do you agree they're vertical
so there's actually a reflection line in
between right in the middle key draw the
reflection line in if you've got another
color there I'm gonna draw mine in like
so can you see that reflection line
that's the line of symmetry between your
X plus 2 and your X minus 2 have a look
at the exponential on the log function
do you see the same symmetry do you see
them sort of coming in toward each other
and then away from each other again
where is the line of symmetry it's still
in the same spot right smack bang in the
middle of them right and then when you
have a look lastly at 2 X and X on two
it also has a line of symmetry but it
strangely it crosses over itself so
you've got it going right there down the
middle what is the equation of this line
of symmetry this is a straight line that
goes at 45 degrees right through the
origin right so that's going to be y
equals x every single time y equals x y
equals x y equals x right so I'm trying
to get you to what feeling a definition
and idea and intuition for what inverses
are right you can think about them as
switching variables you can think about
them as doing a reflection across y
equals x now let's come to this guy Y
cosine X what would it look like if you
turn this over 45 degrees and reflect it
across that
now I'm going to draw it don't draw it
just yet I just want you to see the way
that I do it if we did the reflection
it's quite hard because you're wiggling
around okay you're going to get
something make sure I get this right mmm
like of this I'm gonna just trample all
over my other ones just for the sake of
it okay why do I have to keep drawing it
why do I keep on going on and on and on
up and down what am i reflecting again
I'm reflecting this guy right and this
guy goes on and on and on forever
horizontally so therefore if all I do is
a reflection then this guy should go on
and on and on forever but not
horizontally it's gonna go vertically
right does that make sense now the
reason why I've put this in Dada and
another color is because this is a
problem for us think all the way back to
when we're talking about functions last
year if you have any memory from when
you did that was a long time ago that's
not a function do you notice that what
do you know about functions what is it
about this thing I've just drawn there's
no longer a function every x value or
any x value really can have more than
one y value do you maybe have a test for
this where's my onlys marula here we go
we had a test for this right we would
get a straight line out and what would
we do yeah we would put it vertically
right and we would say oh okay do I
intersect more than once right so do you
remember that was like a really easy
function that broke this for us it was
the circle right you put your circle
across a vertical line you're like oh I
hit once twice it's not a function what
did we call that a relation right so
what I've just drawn here in orange is
the inverse relation this guy okay
that's okay but it's not the inverse
function okay so therefore what I
actually need to do is some kind of
restriction and we're going to come to
this later on so I purposely want you to
draw y equals sine X in there but don't
draw sine inverse just yet we're going
to come to him later on and you're going
to
returned to this page and fill it in
once we're good and ready okay